when i say hall of fame i think of jeff
perlman i think of my great friend jeff
perlman who wrote the book that just
came out as a actually about to come out
the hbo show showtime now it's called
winning time the rise of the lakers
dynasty trailer and jeff i'm so glad
that you came up you were so cool too
about jockeying because when i texted
you yesterday and said can you switch
the 10 and the 11 it's for jerry westman
what are you going to do say no it's
jerry west right when you're a sports
like marshall faulk gets asked these
things all the time come on tv when
you're a sports writer
nobody ever calls you you just sit in
your little hovel in your dark cave so
that's all also susie calls you you you
show up i would hope so you do because i
know where you live rich eisen calls you
think about it
you're here dude i i book tj do i book
it better guess or what come on look i'm
not trying to get involved your guests
are great but i don't want to like you
know i got to stay you got to you got to
take a stand
your guests are better if you don't
stand for something what do you fall for
mike you've got on the show yes you do
it thank you i appreciate that i love
the fact that this is coming out that
you have adam mckay
to option and take your book all the way
what was that like for you to get the
call saying your lakers showtime is now
going to become an hbo show i just
didn't believe it like i truly didn't
believe it and this uh book came out in
2014
it sold really well but you just write a
book to write a book and there's this
guy he was a screenwriter named jim
hecht and his credits were ice age like
that was his credits and he calls me
he's like i love this book i love this
book i swear to god this is a true story
and i don't believe him i believe he
likes a book but i don't he's like i
want to make this we can make this into
something i'm like okay whatever and uh
he's like well let's meet i'll come to
your house i'll come to your house and i
lived in newer shell new york at the
time
he comes on easter 2014 two jews on
easter we're having family dinner he
shows up
and he shows up i swear to god with
three things because there's not that
much to open on grand central station
and easter
shows up in my house with a
block of baker's chocolate
a tomato like a big tomato and a bottle
of wine drink not wine wine drink wine
drink
because i guess they were the only
things you could find and he shows up at
my house on easter and my family's like
who the hell is this guy and my wife
calls me in the kitchen and she's like
who the who is this guy like i don't
know he wants to and he talks and he
talks about it and i don't believe
anything he says
and over the years he's like no it's
going to happen it's going to happen and
one day he says uh adam mckay wants
wants to meet with us
and i didn't know who adam mckay was
my i'm actually being serious advocate
for any of you who's listening he was uh
he and will ferrell were long-time
partners he's one of the most prolific
producers directors writers in hollywood
so i should have known who it was good
job
so i literally go to his house and i'm
googling adam mckay outside his house
like i had no idea who adam mckay was
could you tell by the fact that he had a
great house that he needed a lot of
things
just saying so uh i go in and he's like
i love the book and blah blah blah and
i'm like oh this is great you don't hear
anything and one day you get this
contract from hbo and the next thing you
know
you start seeing john c reilly and sally
field and
it's it's the craziest thing that's ever
happened to me jeff pullman here on the
rich essence show it's called winning
time the rise of the lakers dynasty
that's what is called on hbo the book
was a call of course called showtime
because of the showtime lakers
what made
showtime
so special so sexy and so captivating
i mean i think jerry buss
it's so common now with with the nba and
and the uh
every team has
loud music and every team has dancing
cheerleaders and every team has you know
entertainment out the out the butt
but uh i can't believe i just said that
but back then um
it wasn't a thing
you know you'd have a boring halftime
show
uh it would be very you know boring and
stale and jerry buss comes along and
he's like this has to be showtime this
has to be entertainment people aren't
just coming to watch basketball they're
coming to be entertained and we're going
to start getting celebrities and we're
going to give them seats by the court
and people are going to show up and
they're going to want to see them
and then obviously the the biggest of
the big is they they luck into the
number one pick in the 79 draft and they
get magic johnson and um you know you
just said jerry weston and jerry west is
one of the geniuses in basketball and he
may not admit this too but he wanted
sidney moncrief he wanted city mountain
creek number one and there was his fight
with the lakers magic johnson sydney
moncrief because the argument was we
already have norm nixon who's a great
point guard magic johnson's going to be
the six nine point guard how's that
going to work against small
you know the tiny archibald of the nba
how's it gonna work
and uh jerry bus was steadfast we need
to take this guy this guy has something
special about him and that was sort of
the birth of it
and
in going and trying to recapture
lightning in the bottle
and you're watching your book turn into
a movie
what was
what did they get right do you think
that as we watch we're going to say i
really believe john c reilly as dr boss
all right so
the casting of magic is the most
interesting one to me actually so john c
reilly is a great actor obviously adrian
brody plays pat riley he's fantastic
sally field amazing right
there's this guy named quincy isaiah who
plays magic johnson and i love
everything about his story first of all
like magic he's from michigan he was a
college football player at a small
school in michigan
nobody ever heard of him and you watch
him and he just oozes magic johnson i've
never it's uncanny it's almost like
uh my wife and i watch him
and you'll be like wait is that magic oh
no that's quincy playing magic and they
just they nail it
they just nail it it's one of the best
pieces of casting i've ever seen on any
tv show ever and it just happens to be
based on my book which is
insane which you have to think is still
like absolutely crazy it's ridic i mean
there's this day there's this day a
couple years ago they were filming the
pilot and they said you and your wife
want to make cameos in the pilot and i'm
like
why wouldn't i right
i show up and they have a trailer with
my name on it and yes they misspelled my
last name but it was still my name on
the channel to be kidding me
they they left out the a in perlman so
it was p-e-r-l-m-a-n but i still had a
trailer damn it and uh i show up my wife
shows up and they put us in makeup and
i'm playing a reporter and my wife
actually gets a speaking line she plays
the uh the secretary to rod thornton the
bulls gm and it's all during the the
draft sequence and
craft services all the food is free i'm
like taking out a wallet no no it's free
you can eat it all and is this there's
this magical magical day and the
craziest thing
there's a book called the hate you give
by angie thomas which is a great book
and i had this conversation with her
where she said
there's something so trippy
about
you write this thing
and then you're you're in it like you're
actually
it's a three-dimensional thing come to
life and that's really what it was like
for me it was just one of the weirdest
and coolest experiences of my life
i think there's not a single person in
life who wants to be shown on camera by
an actor
less than jerry west
can you imagine he will be so mortified
because he's so
jerry doesn't like any attention he is
so humble
he will be horrified that he's being
played by a hollywood actor all right so
jason clark plays him
and uh
it's ridiculous how good he is i'm not
just saying i wouldn't like i just
wouldn't bring up it's well you're not
going to say he's stunned no but i
wouldn't say anything if he was like if
he was if i didn't think i wouldn't say
anything and um
the thing about jerry west that i love
there are two guys i've covered who do
this billy bean and jerry west where
they can't watch their own team play and
their team is either whether they're
doing well poorly they're circling
around the arena or billy bean used to
drive his car when the a's were playing
and jason clark captures that like
this sort of thing of jerry west
like perfectly and
i just think it's amazing the guys like
that who really can't take enjoyment
in the highs of it all like the lows
beat them
far more than the highs
uh give them pleasure
it's a really weird
it's a weird phenomenon it's captured
really well i think and you've wrote
you've written the
all-time telling book about the lakers
three-peat that you and i lived through
together as i cover the lakers from 2000
to 2003 during that period and by the
way if i don't have some kind of role
written into this you and i are going to
throw down i'm just saying like
i was there every night remember you
know i was i was gonna wear my
sunglasses because i've gone very
hollywood i'll talk to him have your
people call my people right and by that
i'll call them is that right yeah uh
what
as you look at that era as we look at
the shaq and kobe european shacks coming
on tomorrow what stands out to you about
a moment in that time where you realized
that you were watching you were you were
chronicling you were a part
of something incredibly special and
great unfolding before your eyes oh man
i mean to me
it's when kobe shows up
at his first training camp
and it's 97
and they're all standing in a circle 97
did i get that right 96 excuse me 96 96
and they're all standing in a circle
and this is his first camp
and they're all introducing themselves
it's like hey i'm shaq you know you know
who i am hey i'm eddie jones i played a
temple on nick vinnick and his name my
name's kobe
nobody here is going to punk me
like that was his introduction he's 18
barely 18 years old nobody here is gonna
punk me and it set this tone
and i wouldn't say was a very wise
approach you know like the other
players like who the hell is this guy
but it really set the tone for who that
guy was and the attitude he brought to
basketball he brought it because he had
that ship on his shoulder about being a
kid of affluence right and coming in and
speaking languages and speaking fluent
italian being the son of jelly bean
i think he was trying to
write lay the gauntlet down already that
you can't screw with me and and in fact
you wonder if part of that was and we'll
never really know the answer now but
part of it was just trying to protect
himself right
and trying to guard himself because shaq
was such a different kind of guy
i think um
a lot of his career
was
trying to put forth an image and i
really think it seems like he found
himself after he retired and later in
his career when he wasn't quite the
player and he sort of became this almost
fatherly type figure because i feel like
a lot of his career i think you saw this
was putting up a front i'm tough kobe
you can't mess with me kobe and the guy
was a intellectual
very intelligent
um sensitive human being who always felt
he had to put up a front and i always
think like that has to be so exhausting
to live that life like shaq was the
opposite there's no front what you saw
with shaq was basically what you got
with shaq and kobe had this shell this
plexiglas shield he put up around
himself the older his girls got the more
he became relaxed definitely and he
seemed to almost fit into his own skin
better as the girls got older yeah i
mean i think that's one of the horrible
and there are a million of them horrible
tragedies about his passing is he really
was this guy he was blossoming and
coming into his own and you saw him i
mean what i always think of and i bet
you do too is him
sitting with gigi at that game breaking
down the play and just this beautiful
moment
i just
i mean it's the saddest thing ever
obviously jeff pullman here on the rich
eisen show suzy schuster in for rich
eisen jeff um charles barkley in the
first hour said i think he put it this
way the lakers stink what are your
thoughts on the lakers as they are right
now yeah they stink it's the worst
constructed team
ever
i have a kid who lives down the street
from me named drew who every he lives
and dies with lakers and he's like no i
think they're really getting it together
he's always like they're getting it
together and i'm like drew this team
sucks this is terrible this is the worst
constructed team ever
the westbrook thing is a it's just a
fiasco that we all saw coming from the
beginning
and then the worst thing is you look
around the league and you see brandon
ingram playing well with new orleans new
orleans you saw what caruso was doing
before he got hurt you saw what ball was
doing and they had these nice pieces
and now they're just a really old
it's impossible for them to come out of
the west like actually impossible for
them to come out of the west
disagree
can't say i disagree and especially with
a.d getting hurt with that ankle sprain
because we all know that sometimes a
fracture is a better injury than an
ankle sprain because that ankle sprain
once you do it comes back again and
again street clothes right that's what
barkley's calling him right now street
clothes i think it's a bad sign when the
people i know who are huge laker fans
are super excited about austin reeves
like
everyone i know is like this austin
reeves although he's like when you're
getting excited about the ninth man in
your rotation or a guy who should be the
ninth man in your rotation you have some
issues well that three-pointer was
really pretty last name brockman what do
you got yeah jeff uh quickly switching
the baseball uh you're an amazing book
about barry bonds a while back what did
you make of him not making the hall of
fame this year and all the discussion
that surrounded that this past year with
david ortiz you know getting elected
i love that question um because i was
100 against bonds getting in i've been
outspoken about bonds he shouldn't get
in he cheated he cheated he cheated
and i feel like this year the writers
basically
blew up my own argument like once you
let ortiz in
who we know cheated as well like we know
david ortiz cheated we know he used pds
pd
the moment you say well we're going to
let him in because he's always been nice
to us and he has a nice smile and he's
good with the kids
that ends any argument against bonds
like that's it because that's not what
it's about so to me at this point
i really i've never said this before but
bonds belongs in mcguire belongs in sosa
belongs in clemens belongs in all these
guys like you just decided you you guys
made this decision we're going to let in
this guy because we love him and because
he was nice to us well
fine then you got to let him all in are
you a voter i'm not a voter i'm just a
loud person
[Laughter]
do you think he eventually gets in on
some sort of veterans committee or they
have the
a new recent one about uh i forget the
name of it but do you think they
eventually get in i do because i i think
i would say nine out of ten players i've
spoken with over the years support him
getting in they no none of them like him
right he's one of the least likeable
human beings you'll ever find in your
life at least he was as a player but
there's no denying that he's maybe the
greatest we've ever seen of course and
if we're again if we're gonna if we're
just not gonna care about cheating if
that's just not a factor he has to be in
this kind of goes back to what jerry
said too jerry west of course our guest
in the last hour is uh is that
it's how you treat people now
i happen to
enjoy interviewing barry bonds i was
very lucky to have a good relationship
with him so i covered him
for the last couple years of his career
and throughout the world series
but
most people didn't have that
relationship with him and i feel like
speaking on his behalf i feel like he
had a lot in his past that he hadn't
unpacked and that he took that out in
the field with him and that's my own
personal perspective but that's mine
the fact of the matter is is
where do you draw the line i mean you
either play the game with integrity
and
you or you don't i mean if ortiz gets in
right and he has but he's been a great
guy
but clemens doesn't get in or
barry doesn't get in
it's not a popularity contest it's a
numbers game i agree it's the same with
shilling like shilling hasn't gotten in
i agree with nothing curt schilling says
ever there's there's no human being on
this planet i disagree with more than
kurt schilling
but he belongs in the hall of fame like
that's irrelevant what i think about his
political opinions is completely
irrelevant he belongs in a hall of fame
and again if we're going to let cheaters
in we're just acknowledging this guy
cheated but he's a nice guy then we have
to let him the ones who weren't nice
guys too have to
what are you working on now what's the
next book i have a bo jackson biography
coming out in uh october hmm we know a
lot about that
life between baseball and football
through dion how's bo's house in closet
that i don't know yeah you gotta find
out you gotta find out where the money
goes yeah he's a hunter
he's a hunter
he used to
take his bow and shoot it in the
clubhouse
and the players were complaining to the
gm and be like you know bo and no one
had the guts to say anything to both
like no one's gonna be like listen beau
you really need to think about this
yeah it's amazing jeff wasn't there a
story about beau as a kid that he would
kill pigs by throwing rocks at them he's
stealing my best material that's true
the mother was a uh
i mean you can his nickname so beau
derives from bohog which is borehog he
lived in the deep south in bessemer
alabama
and uh
i've been to this farm there was a up
the street from where he lives
there was this guy who raised pig boars
and bo and his friends one day show up
and they they're with rocks and sticks
and they're just beating the crap
out of this
enormous borehog
and um
they get caught
and they threaten to send beau to uh a
way to you know private military school
and uh
it's sort of the moment where he first
realizes maybe i shouldn't be such a
horrible kid he was a horrible
horrible kid as far as behavior which
he's acknowledged but really interesting
guy oh god i love you but and now i now
i hate bo jackson no no no he's great
he's a great guy he's great he's great
sure yeah you know how i feel about
animals he's no marshmallow
he's no marshall faulkner that that's a
tough sell don't beat up a borehog he
was a kid he's a kid
a good lord all right jeff what's your
twitter handle because you are a funny
at jeff perlman yeah that's great with
an a with an a yeah when does a winning
time the rise of the lakers dynasty come
out march 6th on hbo all right watch it
on hbo please
and then stay tuned of course for my
huge part in the lakers 3 pete you got
it television
right yeah yeah just keep me posted let
me know what my call time is and spell
my name right will you please do my best
i'll get you a trailer hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here